let's look at some stunning clips you
may have heard or you may not that the
us trucker convoy advocating for freedom
from
something uh mandates i guess that
mostly don't exist or i don't know the
us trucker convoy is demanding their
freedom they have been oppressed by
tyranny and different things they've
started to get close to washington dc
and uh some interviews have now been
done with them and it seems like a skit
here are the good liars the good liars
who do they do this really really well
interviewing one trucker yesterday
and she is most concerned that they want
to
digitize
excuse me i i can't
i can't even say the word
digitize
us like you know how you would tile a
shower
and digitize so it's digitized
she doesn't want to be digitized
wow take a look are you really concerned
about right now
i don't want them to digitize
you don't want them what the digitalis
i don't want to take medicine that'll
hurt people what was the what was the
word you used though i haven't heard
that digital
digital
digital
and what what does that mean
they're trying to
they're trying to make us robots they're
trying to make it where we have no
choice and nothing to where they control
maybe by digitize she means like made
into an android or something oh they can
control us from what they put in our
bodies
and eventually we'll actually be robots
according to what they're saying not
robots but according to what they've
already got a
full
man-made working female robot maybe i
guess she's talking about
like those sex robots that recently made
news i don't even know but how how wild
is that guys like how much of this
entire trucker convoy fiasco is just the
result of bad education and confused
people i mean this woman seems to not
have any idea why she's there she's
there because they want to digitize us i
mean it's is it is it that you know we
talk about
well you know there's sort of like these
misunderstandings about what liberty and
freedom are and people want freedoms
absent responsibilities and it's like
are we just doing too much and it's just
like they want to digitize us it's just
confusion and bad education is it just
that simple
um here's another interview with some uh
truckers i guess is what we're calling
them um
and the these folks want uh they believe
the russian invasion might be fake it's
just it's not really going on i guess
easily fake a war if they wanted to all
they would do is just like film a few
things are you aware that the majority
of the pictures that they've been
showing regarding the alleged war in
ukraine are from prior conflicts and are
unrelated to ukraine yeah that's what i
was saying we shouldn't have anything to
do with it at all
let them figure out their own mess the
very patriotic honking in the background
as you can hear state
has always made putin to look like the
bad guy
um but he's a good guy freedom
okay
so um the war is fake also that's
another you know pretty big brain take
and then um here's one more clip of a
guy wearing
i guess some kind of uh
head
it's almost like a chain link armor i'm
sure these things have specific names
but i don't know them take a listen to
this guy
is this a crusade
i believe it's a people's crusade
you know it's a crusade in the fact that
people have to
fight the evil in the world man and the
evil is
uh well you're heading down to the
evil in the in the world and people have
to band together and fight on the side
of the lord
you know god wills it man fox wanted to
do a story on
the banks here
so anyway so that guy thinks that
they're basically doing i guess the i
guess god wants there to be
a convoy
and they are there doing their thing uh
now one other thing just that this might
be of interest
they
i i actually this is actually sort of
smart like they're realizing that if
they go into dc they
they might actually get arrested
blocking traffic different things so one
of their i guess leaders is framing it
as
they're trying to sort of like goad us
into going to dc to then arrest us or
something take a listen
i am fearful
brian
and the organizers are fearful
of them trying to do to us what they did
to those involved in january 6th
it is our belief that they will
try to do that
so with that said
we are making
diplomatic
moves
that means that we're not
that means
at this time meaning today
and tomorrow
we are not
and will not go into dc properly
so that was disappointing to some of the
convoy people but others realize you
know they're trying to set us up like
they set up the rioters and we're not
going into dc basically the entire thing
has fallen flat and the interviews with
the vast majority of the folks are
indistinguishable from what would be a
saturday night live skit when saturday
night live was at its funniest
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective i love vincero's watches
you've heard me talk about them before
they now offer sunglasses and a bunch of
other premium accessories for men and
women vincero is committed to creating
exceptionally crafted watches and
accessories and doing so ethically fair
pricing carbon neutrality vincero puts
their principles first which is
important to me i just picked up the
rogue from vincero in gunmetal and red i
love the intricate design on the watch
face and the multiple sub dials the
durable black silicone strap looks great
with just about anything i'm wearing in
all of vincero's products whether it's
the watches the glasses men's or women's
you can just see and feel the quality so
if you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15
off all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below